[gentle music]
Gomez: Wallapop is app
with a simple concept.
Just consists
on a flea market
on your mobile phone
and every item is localized.
On your mobile device,
Wallapop simulates
a walk around your neighborhood
and you start discovering
the stuff
that your neighbors are selling.
Really provides
this impulsive buying behavior.
Very different to common
classified experience.
There was a point of my life
when I decided
it's time to start
a new challenge.
So I decided to start
Wallapop in Barcelona.
The day one
we were only two people
and after one month
of the development
we achieved
the number one position
in Spain in the Play Store.
One of the keys of Wallapop
has been its simplicity.
People from 15 year olds
to 60 has been selling stuff
on the Wallapop site.
And more than 70% of our users
come from the Android platform.
Gui: My name is Marta
and I work on Wallapop
as a growth hacking manager.
We started using store listing
experiments one year ago
and after testing we optimized
the organic downloads by 17%.
At the beginning
we started testing
too much things
at the same time,
so result wasn't congruent
so we decided
to test step-by-step.
What we decided to test first
was the short description.
And we optimized 6%
of organic downloads.
For the next test was with
our Business Intelligence Team
and they told us which were
the top sold products.
So we did
four different experiments
with the four
highlighted products
to test how attractive
it was for the users.
What we found out
while testing this
is that there were
two type of users:
the decisive users
and the experienced users.
So what we did
is to work on a cover
that will be very recognizeable
for this decisive users
using the main slogan
of Wallapop
and the things that they saw
on the TV ad.
We even test shuffling
the screens
to see what effect
this will have
and we see very good results.
When creating your
Google Play store page
you have to think about
the first impression
because it might be the only
chance you have
to convince a user
to download your app.
Gomez:
Since we started Wallapop
we have grown
a very huge family.
This incredible success
has been something that
is gonna happen
once in a lifetime
and I'm very grateful
to have been able
just to lead all this team.
It has been the toughest
and the greatest experience
of my life.